bonsoir avoue marc fesneau en soir tout
est pardonné entre emmanuel macron et
les maires de france moi je tente en
tout cas le congrès ces tâches
effectivement cet après midi par un
discours du président ça a permis six
ans mon père me permettait de dire
l'expression de remettre un peu l'église
au milieu du village que le président la
république face à la fois un bilan un
bilan lucide de ce qui a été fait de ce
qui reste à faire aussi il faut se le
dire parce que le chemin était on
partait de loin aussi sur un certain
nombre de sujets et la défiance qui
s'était noué s'était nouée dans le
quinquennat précédent et celui d'avant
ou au fond on n'avait pas sous toujours
été au rendez vous des promesses et
c'est bien que le président a rappelé
juste une seconde là dessus ce qu'elles
avaient été ses promesses qui ferait ce
qui ferait pas et qu'au fond et puis
c'est un bilan et d'essai dresser des
perspectives qui je pense qu'il faut
qu'on cesse et je trouve que le message
du président était très fort de ce point
de vue là d'opposer les collectivités et
l'état parce que tout ça est un tout
c'est la puissance publique au fond ont
fait défaut aux uns et aux autres quand
on essaie de dresser des barrières entre
louis il a dit emmanuel macron c'est un
peu un temps fort de ce discours que
quand il a dénoncé le débat mortifère
des élus contre l'état qu'est ce qu'ils
visaient en particulier mais on a
entendu des expressions parfois des élus
pas c'est pas normal je sais pas la
majorité d'entre eux d'ailleurs mais de
quelques élus qui expliquait qu'il
faisait tellement mieux que l'état que
l'état était en permanence à critiquer
qu'au fond l'état n'était pas auprès des
gens de macron avait commencé le
quinquennal et en les traitant de
clientélisme il avait pas dit les choses
comme ça il avait d'ailleurs été au
congrès je suis en 2017 j'étais
président groupe il avait expliqué
d'ailleurs qui on avait besoin d'eux et
deux parce que ça c'est bien de le dire
c'est mieux le montrer qu'il fallait
faire de la différenciation c'est à dire
tenir compte de la réalité des
territoires il avait dit une stabilité
fiscale et financière enfin la taxe
d'habitation et ça sera compensée et pas
de grands big bang tous avaient commencé
leur prêt at il précisé marc fesneau
qu'est ce qui dysfonctionne ont entendu
les propos d'emmanuel macro été assez
précis sur la décentralisation
qu'est-ce qu'il ya trop de strates pas
assez de simplification administrative
sapeurs des échecs du quinquennat a
malgré tout est noté et des précédents
alors pour tout vous dire il n'y a pas
de l'ensemble des textes sur lesquels
nous sommes interpellés par les élus
j'ai fait beaucoup de congrès des maires
récemment oui pour expliquer la
politique du gouvernement et comme vous
savez je suis un élu local depuis 26 ans
le prince et la sédimentation d'un
certain me taxer sur la plupart des
textes sur lequel on crie au loup et qui
sont critiques aujourd'hui ces textes
ont été votés et à 5 10 ou 15 ans et
d'août on voit seulement les compos les
conséquences désormais les grandes
communautés de communes la fusion des
régions le la pratique avons fait que
par la parler volonté d'économie on a
fait déménager si on peut dire les
fonctionnaires d'état du territoire en
particulier des départements tout ça on
paye tout ça c'est ça qu'il faut et donc
il faut qu'on retisse des choses et
c'est long et de faut qu'il y ait une
relation de confiance est à dire un
contrat et c'est comme quand on dise pas
aux collectivités quand on leur dit on
maintient des choses on les maintient
vraiment et quand on a besoin d'ajuster
des dispositifs qu'on le fasse aussi bon
françois hollande de fait les grandes
régions vous souvenez je reviens très
bien c'est l usine à gaz c'était sur
toile et marisa semblait faire allusion
c'était assez méprisant des territoires
parce que ça a été fait vous le savez il
ya eu plusieurs cas dont vous aviez été
bénéficiaires sur un coin de table 1
dimanche soir parce qu'il fallait sortir
une carte et on a tout d'un coup décidé
que celle-là fusionner avec celle là
parce que ça arrange était littell
puissant locales et moi je pense que ça
n'a pas été respectueux des territoires
et des habitants et des élus de ces
territoires emmanuel macron a dit autre
chose il dit nous avons trop souvent
confondue la décentralisation avec la
délégation de compétence grosso modo
faut aller plus loin oui il dit il dit à
juste titre que la décentralisation
c'est pas simplement voulait que la
compétence est exercée par l'état et
vous allez vous en début les collections
des moyens et de la capacité des
déclarations quand les corps se régler
en plus d'autonomie et jacqueline
gourault va régulièrement encore à celui
même mêmes accords ses galets sur les
mecs comme tel là bas c'est non non
c'est pas pardon c'est inexact que ces
noms parce que d'abord sur un certain
nombre de compétences les corses ont
déjà beaucoup plus loin que les autres
par ailleurs et ça reviendra à mon avis
dans le débat institutionnel mais déjà
par la voix de la différenciation les
corses pour faire un certain de choses à
propos on peut aller jusque là on estime
à l'est après on est dans un pays le
président de la république l'a
d'ailleurs appelé qui est assez attachés
au principe d'égalité et donc il faut
aussi qu'on puisse maintenir c'est cette
tension entre la réalité de la corse par
exemple qui est une île et cassé
contraintes avec la réalité des hôtels
est un principe et le réel vous dit marc
fesneau demain ils se déplacent dans les
hauts de france emmanuel macron sur ses
terres
de naissance si je puis dire pour parler
développement des territoires aller
c'est un président en campagne
non mais là mais le président la
république à l'ina parce qu'aux derniers
jours
j'ai fait ici c'est encore moi j'ai vu
quelques fin de quinquennat deux
septennats désormais quand les
présidents ne bougez pas on disait ça y
est ils sont en roue libre il n'aurait
forme plus ça fait un an qu'ils ne font
plus rien et quand on est sur le terrain
comporte des réformes on dirait qu'un
campagne le président avait dit annoncé
et c'est bien d'avoir un président de la
république qui dit ce qu'il avait dit
qu'il allait faire
et qui fait pardon ce qu'il avait dit
qu'il allait faire et donc je trouve que
c'est bien que le président de la
république jusqu'au dernier moment
gouverne il va faire un bilan d'un
certain nombre de politiques qui ont été
menées dans les territoires avec la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
quand on fait le bilan c'est qu'on va
faire des propositions mais non c'est
aussi c'est aussi pour voir ce qu'on a
fait non mais je pense que ces 13 je ne
partage pas ce sentiment je trouve que
c'est très bien qu'on fasse des annonces
on développe un projet et qu'après on
voit ce qui s'est passé si ça a marché
ou pas etc on réajuste en tous les cas
vous au modem parce que j'aurais pu
mieux se rappelle que vous êtes un des
hauts responsables au côté de françois
bayrou au mouvement démocrate vous
préparer la présidentielle il ya ce
mouvement ensemble citoyens qui est
sorti du chapeau hier soir il faut
accumuler modem agir le la république en
marche bien évidemment et le nouveau
parti horizon d'edouard philippe mais
c'est une machine électorale ça mais ça
c'est à côté de ce que vous mettez des
services d'emmanuel mcrory c'est ça que
cela marcherait place organise dans un
paysage est d'accord c'est compliqué de
répondre à la question ce n'est qu'il
est candidat je comprends c'est que la
majorité s'organise que cette majorité
souhaite que le président m'a qu'on soit
à nouveau candidat et qu'elle s'organise
en conséquence et compense par ailleurs
qui a besoin d'organiser cette majorité
à la fois dans sa composante centrale et
globalement dans son élargissement à
droite et à gauche ça me paraît pas je
me paraît utile et préparer le gleut le
partage législatif oui mais c'est une
deuxième étape mais c'est bien aussi
d'abord qu'on se mette d'accord sur de
grands principes sur ce qu'on a envie de
porter comme message de la
présidentielle le message d'unité c'est
celui là qui compte est évidemment après
y aura la question des législatives
c'est pas un parti unique c'est la
volonté initiale d'avoir un parti
marc fesneau je fais vibrer le centriste
qui est en jeu c'est l'udf quoi en
version domicile non non non parce que
je pense que c'est d'abord c'était là je
vois que vous connaissez effectivement
nous avons quelques souvenirs sur ces
sujets là de l'udf non c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose c'est l'idée du
président du modem
l'idée aussi est partagé je crois par un
certain nombre de gens de remarcher que
le dépassement il passe par un espace
central qui est puissant ç'a failli le
faire comme on dit en 2007 avec françois
bayrou le président de la république a
permis à des gens qui venaient de la
droite et de la gauche de se parler
parce que l'espace central était fort
donc il faut que cet espace central se
solidifie et par ailleurs que ceux qui à
droite et à gauche et se revendique
comme tel et c'est très bien vu veulent
travailler avec nous veulent se met sous
une travail commun le fassent très peu
de temps il reste malheureusement marc
fesneau vous a entendu les gérard
larcher sur tv5 mans dans l'émission
face aux territoires de cyril viguier il
dit si un rebond de l'épidémie de kobe
de 19 il faut en repasser par le
parlement c'est oui c'est non on est
toujours repasser par le parlement
d'ailleurs les attendait d'ailleurs les
mesures qui ont été votées elles sont
activés et au bout d'un mois on repasse
devant le parlement pour obtenir la
provocation je crois qu'on pourra dire
quand même on voit ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays européens pour l'instant
la situation est plutôt ce contrôle je
pense qu'on a pris les bonnes décisions
au bon moment ici on est au 11e ou 12e
texte strictement sur ces questions
sanitaires qu'ils soient passés devant
le parlement et je pense que à la fois
dans l'urgence qui était la nôtre mais
dans l'exigence que porte à juste titre
le président larcher de faire
fonctionner les institutions on a plutôt
été au rendez vous et donc on le sera à
nouveau le cas échéant on est très
centriste merci à tous les cas je vais
pas changer marc fesneau au ministre
délégué en charge des relations avec le
parlement et de la participation
citoyenne
d'abord été l'invité ici même du 18 50
francs sauf merci à vous de votre
invitation